are you a Phil events are in 10 so you
know right now just because usually with
the so many people there are close to
the fighters it isn't like there's a lot
of people in attendance that are not
friends and families or they don't know
somebody who's fighting on the car
personally so there's a lot of energy
it's very very very very uh energetic uh
crowd to be a part of because so many
people are very vested in what's what's
going on that night we have been super
blessed United fight league has had its
first event in February and I would say
that some of these Fighters that give
United Fight League a chance are
incredible studs they are going to be
the Champions like you know Jose Delgado
or Shane sabnoski or a moon it's pretty
amazing that they have just kind of
fallen into a lap right now because uh
they they got amazing Futures ahead of
them